nestled in the hills of New York's
Hudson River Valley lies the town of
Sleepy Hollow
a place where a spooky legend meets
modern day life Dutch settlers came here
in the 1600s to farm trap and fish at
this historic manor you can still
experience life as it was in the 17th
and 18th centuries it's a fun place to
visit but it's the tale of a gangly
schoolmaster and a headless horseman
that really would Sleepy Hollow and now
the legends of Sleepy Hollow is the
ultimate creepy story now dwelling in
these parts in a tenant house was a
certain schoolmaster by the name of
Ichabod Crane American author Washington
Irving visited this area as a boy and is
believed to have based The Legend of
Sleepy Hollow on people and places right
in this town Bill Lent is the sexton of
the old Dutch Church he knows everything
there is to know about the legend
showing tourists where the famous
characters are buried and when he was
writing the book he remembered the name
on the stone Katrina Van Tassel lead
female character in The Legend of Sleepy
Hollow as the story goes Ichabod Crane
fled across the bridge to the old Dutch
Church RACI to escape the Headless
Horseman
words people Ichabod urged his horse
gunpowder on come come but the horse
needed no further urgings had took off
and headed down to get to that
churchyard bridge every year Sall
Tarantino plays the Headless Horseman in
the town's Halloween Festival the
hardest problem is a real
jack-o'-lantern we've tried that several
times a good-sized jack-o'-lantern with
the right candle and it weighs about
pounds and hold that out on your arm and
try to control the horse at 40 miles an
hour in the dark doesn't work too well
Irving did not actually write the legend
here in Sleepy Hollow but he loved the
area so much he returned as an adult to
live on this 24 acre estate right on the
Hudson River and nearly two centuries
after oving wrote The Legend of Sleepy
Hollow the history and landscape of this
place
still inspire and the legend lives on if
you listen you'll hear the unmistakable
clattering of hooves of the Headless
Horseman beware he still rides he still
rides